and sportscrafters  thoughts on the shield i love the shield  fake mackie  always up to no good design resigns yeah  this is  a crushing crushing display  by the world champion  what a game and he's showing he  he still has a lust for chess even after  being eliminated yeah  what a game that was also the right  position for him to get actually just to  get  interested and not not going and he  could  sacrifice the exchange and upon some  pure positional compensations and uh  well  that's uh just a brilliant game  from the the world champion yeah  very impressive and also credit to  fedocia for  yeah playing chess with magnus because  frankly you don't see  these games from the world champion that  often but it's also because people you  know  they know how to keep it keep it a  little drier  and today if you say if went for it it  can lead to masterpiece like this which